na ja aber wo ist das rezept geblieben
von den plätzchen die wir lieben wer hat
das rezept verschleppt na dann müssen
wir es packen einfach frei nach schnauze
wagen schmeißt den ofen an ran
ja hallo leute ich jetzt wieder eure mal
wanne und heute bin ich nicht alleine
ich habe es nie zu fest und zusammen
machen wir eine neue folge
wie schmeckt sie die weihnachts hits
unter euch schon lange gemerkt haben
machen wir heute die plätzchen aus dem
song in der verein gibt zu mein kinn
leckerei
das rezept ist ganz einfach wir folgen
einfach dem 26 ja also los geht brauchen
wir nicht schokolade zucker honig und
puttgarden und ein bisschen sind das
stimmt
eine portion schokolade schokolade honig
war abgelesen
ich wusste nämlich nicht was du gerade
ist zitronat und dann wusste auch nicht
was die tonart ist sie doch sind diese
kandierten zitronenschalen wirklich gar
nicht schmecken oder sie sind man die
sie findet man stollen dass sie voll
geil auch um ein bisschen angst drauf zu
beißen es kein morgen wochen wenn ich
ein bisschen sinn
2 es sieht aus wie weihnachts in der
schüssel butter mehl und milch verrühren
zwischendurch einmal probieren und dann
kommt das sei vorbei
zudem machen wir jetzt unsere lokale
schokolade honig mischung rein und
verrühren alles miteinander machen nicht
alles rein weil wir zu viel gemacht
haben wirklich die einzige werk an das
wohl sein
die einzige mengenangabe in diesem song
ist ja tatsächlich das ei stammt ja es
sieht aus wie ein richtig angst cookie
teig ja aber da muss man so ein bisschen
kritiker werden ja noch mit ein bisschen
mehr auf und dann sieht wie leicht das
ergibt witzel mal zur seite treten denn
ich brauche platz zum kneten sind die
finger rein du schwein anna wo muss
jetzt der teig rein damit er sich so
richtig schön ausruhen kann sind die
plätzchen die wir stechen erstmal auf
den ofen blechen warten wir gespannt
verbrannt oder auch nicht das sind sie
unsere plätzchen aus der
weihnachtsbäckerei sechs platziert jetzt
stellen uns allerdings der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt's
nicht den penis ich nehme den
scheißhaufen
ja geil ja auf jeden fall empfehlenswert
die plättchen aus der weihnachtsbäckerei
natürlich könnt ihr die kicks auch mit
zuckerguss dekorieren oder mit so
sternchen
da es aber kreativität wir haben die
förmchen für die plätzchen selber
gemacht und wenn ihr wissen wollt wie
das geht wie man's ja fernsehen machen
kann dann müsst ihr jetzt auf annas
kanal gehen denn da bis das video dazu
in der weihnachtsbäckerei gibt so manche
leckerei zwischen mehl und milch macht
so manch eine riesengroße kleckerei in
weihnachtsbäckerei weihnachtsbäckerei
und schaut bei anna vorbei